amnesty international conducted a three
borough census of surveillance cameras
in new york and found more than 15 000
cameras in public spaces this is just
the part of the iceberg we can see a
2021 survey found that about 17 of
american respondents own smart security
cameras many were private doorbell
cameras when you look at how many other
brands of cameras there are out there
we're probably talking about hundreds of
thousands of cameras these sensors have
also become a lot more intelligent
they're able to identify moving objects
all of which makes the data much much
richer your life can be rewound and your
secrets can be revealed wired spoke to
several experts about the explosion of
surveillance tech how police use it and
what the dangers of it might be
[Music]
that could only be imagined back in the
1998 film enemy of the state pretty much
exists today complete with smart cameras
and high altitude aerial imaging in the
last two decades cameras have gotten a
lot cheaper they've gotten smaller
they've gotten lighter a lot of the nypd
camera systems have 4k resolution nik
vision capabilities 360 monitoring or
have a swivel mount they could zoom in
some of them are even positioned where
they can see into the bedrooms of new
yorkers
we see growing drone deployment across
the country the earliest predator
cameras came in this giant sensor ball
that same
sensing power
is now available
on drone cameras that weigh less than a
kilogram arthur holland michelle's book
argues that domestic law enforcement's
adoption of militarized drones and wide
area surveillance was born out of
america's wars in the middle east
war in the last two decades has actually
come to resemble policing more than what
traditionally was associated with
conflict the technologies themselves
didn't need a lot of reworking or
recalibrating in order to have obvious
use cases domestically
a single red kite unit can continuously
image an entire city-sized area in
medium resolution this company's
marketing video shows an example of
persistent wide area motion imagery or
whammy it allows for the tracking of
potentially hundreds of individuals
simultaneously so once an incident is
observed law enforcement can rewind and
track persons of interest in the area
all the way back to their homes if you
want to go back weeks in the footage and
see everywhere an individual has been
you can do that because the camera is
always recording the entire frame if you
map the route you take to school to work
to
church or to a mosque you can't get
there unseen and in the age of facial
recognition that means you can't get
there untracked
we know that the nypd's use of facial
recognition is growing every year and
they're not an outlier that's true for
police departments around the country
and it's now increasingly common to see
it used for graffiti shoplifting other
low-level offenses in fact many major
retailers have used or currently use
image recognition cameras to monitor
people in their stores so how does it
work facial recognition works in very
specific situations for example when we
enter the airport in a passport control
and it uses face rack to check our face
against our passport as it has to check
one image against another image we call
this a one-to-one comparison on the
public camera for example if you search
for a specific person for example a
robber you're not doing a one-to-one
comparison anymore but you do a one to
possibly
thousands of faces and there it becomes
less reliable the problem is that facial
recognition depends a lot on the quality
of the photo if you're looking at
someone straight on if you have them
well lit if you have a high resolution
image it can be pretty accurate but
that's not how most camera footage comes
in from crime scenes you get blurry
images taken at night low resolution
from an off angle just seeing the side
of someone's face
facial recognition is only as good as
the data recorded and the database it's
being compared against the first type of
database used in facial recognition are
the ones maintained by law enforcement
there are also databases generated by
departments of transportation or dmvs
that collects people's passport photo or
driver's license photo there have been
cases where the law enforcement agency
has grainy cctv image of an individual
who they're looking for and they may
pass that to the dmv and run a facial
recognition search and the third
category of databases is potentially the
largest of all social media we see
facial recognition firms like clearview
ai going onto
social media sites like facebook and
twitter and instagram and just scraping
data taking our images in bulk
downloading them ingesting them into
their database chances are that whoever
you are watching this right now your
image is in a clearview ai database and
there's nothing you can do about it
police are increasingly turning to
so-called fusion systems to help them
connect the dots streamlining what once
took countless hours of pavement
pounding video watching and digging
through various databases and the more
data there is out there it becomes more
and more complicated for our end users
to really find information that they are
looking for florian matusek works for
genotech in vienna they make citygraph a
fusion software system that pulls in
various threads of data for law
enforcement under a central display
window you could tell cd graph i want to
see every time there was a theft
reporter in a radius of 500 meters this
gives you a very good filtering to find
more relevant information more relevant
events by combining different data
sources and show you this information on
the map another big player in the
intelligence fusion space is microsoft
which helped expand the new york police
department's in-house machine learning
fusion system initially developed to
prevent terrorism after 9 11. the nypd
uses a product called the domain
awareness system effectively a fusion
tool
which consolidates all of the
nypd's
data that may be used in investigations
in a single program in a single app that
police officers can even have on their
smartphones footage from the city's
thousands of cctv cameras license plate
readers criminal record information if a
report of a
crime comes through they can open the
software pull up license plate reader to
see what vehicles were nearby
not only is the data getting organized
and the cameras getting smarter they're
all connected to the internet now now
that may seem like not such a big deal
but once a cctv camera is connected to
the internet that information can be
shared widely and instantaneously that
makes these enormous repositories of
data available to really anybody who has
the access code in their ongoing
cataloging of surveillance cameras
throughout new york city albert
foxconn's group stop discovered a
potential security vulnerability by
searching the internet for the ip
addresses of these cameras what we found
was one company hick vision that had
left its cameras unshielded most
companies hide the location of their
devices but hick vision didn't we found
more than 16 000 hick vision cameras in
new york city hick vision is a chinese
manufacturer of internet-enabled
surveillance cameras it's controlling
shares are owned by the chinese
government that's why some software
manufacturers like genetech avoid using
hicvision sensors for their systems
certain chinese camera manufacturers do
not take cyber security
so seriously as they should any time
that you
digitize and connect surveillance data
you create an attack surface from actors
both within and beyond so how do we
watch the watchers how do we make sure
that the images going from camera to
cloud are protected one line of defense
is video encryption software in real
time it pixelates all movement in the
image so you can imagine if there's an
operator sitting in front of the screens
watching the videos the operator does
not know who he or she is watching if
really something happened and evidence
is needed then it's possible to go back
into the recording and based on user
privileges to access the original video
but even encrypted video can be unlocked
by law enforcement if they have a
warrant sometimes the government doesn't
even need a warrant we see police
getting a direct link to these camera
systems amazon rings partnership with
police thousands of agreements with
different police departments setting up
law enforcement portals where it's
easier for officers to identify the
cameras in an area and to send requests
for footage it's your choice but the
truth is
people don't feel free to refuse and
even if you're not willing to hand it
over if it exists on amazon servers or
google servers they can hand over your
footage whether you like it or not we
all certainly want to reduce violent
crime especially when it appears to be
on the upward trend but we have to be
very conscious of the costs of having
these technologies if you live in a city
and you see that the mayor is using
robotic systems or drones or artificial
intelligence to watch the city you're
gonna think twice perhaps about going to
a protest you're going to think twice
about what you say or do in the
aftermath of george floyd's murder we
saw customs and border protection
working with state and local police
departments to deploy predator-style
drones to surveil protests perhaps the
most high profile case has been that of
derrick ingram who police accused of
using a bullhorn too close to an
officer's ear police used a photo taken
of him at a rally and identified him by
matching it to social media
they stormed his block sent heavily
armed officers to surround his building
to intimidate him to retaliate against
him because of his activism all while
holding a facial recognition printout in
their hand when we talk about this
technology it's not about some abstract
violation of our rights further
automation through so-called predictive
policing systems have their own pitfalls
when you look underneath the algorithm
it could we see a lot of pseudoscience
and silicon valley snake oil and the
more we collect and the more we combine
the more there is a danger that we as
humans
trust technology too much and think that
it is perfect so this is why we should
never go in a direction where this
information is combined automatically
and decisions are being made
automatically based on it part of what i
find so dangerous here isn't just that
we have more cameras isn't just the way
that they can be misused by police but
the fact that we have this growing
culture of surveillance driven fear
where people are constantly retreating
behind their cameras worried more and
more about their neighbors trained by
these platforms to view them as a threat